hey it's Larry Hub Xbox Live's Major
Nelson and I'm excited to be joined by
this cardboard box today
stop it oh no I mean this is our Major
Nelson moment though cuz tomorrow we're
joined by this cardboard box which
contains the Xbox one X so Microsoft are
kind enough to send us this is our
review unit we did not purchase this
ourselves
no only given to us for the purposes of
writing about yes as is our job so let's
see what's inside
hopefully it cuts the Box open it you
find out what's in the park in the bag
oh okay so I mean it's actually quite I
mean Lex on the outside it looks like a
generic cardboard box but it's got some
nice little holes this is why you should
never judge a box never judge a box by
it's outside I bought outside come hey
exteriors
it's got like some nice little branding
in there I mean you probably won't get
this when you purchase one but if you do
though good good job good job
this is what this is what we're all here
to see the Xbox one X it's I remember
picking up my original Xbox one yeah and
lord have mercy that box was unwieldy it
was a big one yeah let me get scissors
massive this is a lot slicker it looks
bigger than the Xbox one s obviously
yeah but still manageable if you were
looking to go to the shop and put this
in a bag to carry it home you won't have
that much of a tricky time whereas
original Xbox one I thought you're
saying like someone's gonna rub you
awesome oh no Amy it's always gonna rub
you this is sturdy enough that if you
hit with them you could probably
definitely give them a concussion and
not also damage okay I do if someone
can't run up on you do what you gotta do
from all right okay dance so it comes
with already off the bat we have an xbox
game pass and Xbox Live Gold yeah trial
how long is the trial court let me have
a look why is it that it's a really long
long piece of paper 14 days free Xbox
Live Gold a hundred great games for a
month of experts games that's their
Netflix dancer
so you'll get a little taster of that
it's like I'm gonna make a analogy to a
drug dealer but maybe I shouldn't do
that here we also have like a brief
getting started guide right here
hot flowchart action to be honest though
there's only four steps yeah pretty good
that's because there's no connecting
here so please connect yeah we are
filming this the day after connect with
sadly Ken can't alright alright now
let's get inside
okay here's it so Jonah I'm just gonna
pull oh oh that's it
okay so let's have a look at the control
accessories accessories so we have
because we are in Europe we have gotta
lead a far cry you'll agree from the
bricks that came with the original x1
that brick in here we have a lovely HDMI
Kip yep I like these ones because they
have the thick edges to seize to seize
and here of course we have is a normal
controller an elite controller I find
out it is I I have the original Xbox one
and so matches my controller no longer
connects to it and I've done nothing I
treat my my consoles with the utmost
respect it's just like I'm not going
anymore
so hopefully with my new ok I think this
one actually doesn't come with a cable
but you can connect generic yes you
could just connect it okay okay Mona
true of course this is again I don't
think it is I think you never let me
have any fun okay you want to do some
scissoring okay well okay okay Matt I
finished looking at this they're getting
a very PlayStation vibe off of it here
I'm getting a big place running like the
matte black finish
it's slick but it also reminds me of the
PlayStation ok so
let's turn this bad boy around hit
things out I really like the look of it
yeah look it's so small it is you know
it is man yeah yep it's got a much much
lower profile than the original Xbox one
and also the Xbox one s like the Xbox
one s is smaller but still I mean I'm
picturing the one I've got my desk it's
quite chunky maybe it's cause it's a
white one I'm constantly seeing yeah
well there's a black one it looks like
it will fit into a nice like home
entertainment system kind of just to the
front here we have the Xbox one turn on
turn on actual button they did that with
the 1s right did that were the 1s
thank God because I felt like if I could
if I breathed in the direction of my
xbox one it would turn on one of my cats
has figured out that it's a touch base
thing and like we'll just walk up to it
and just put our face right on it
brilliant so yeah we've got the the
button to connect your controller so
like a lot of ventilation here because
they have the ventilation at the top you
can see along the bottom it's not no no
it's not the that's not air plot so you
get air flow from the top and on the
bottom and on the back so plenty of keep
dumping ability here yeah look at that
good yeah so on the back out ports HDMI
AC my power
HDMI out in USB USB I are out yep anyone
who's bought like audio setups yeah
you're in there and the ethernet cable
so no connect cable as obviously said
said earlier because that thing is dead
so already on the top as well we've got
a nice little kind of small Xbox logo
and there's one of those Oh
on bottom sadly the screen on the front
as I said before it's not there we are
all hoping that you know it's just for
developers but we were kind of hoping
that maybe you could get it on there and
you know by the end of this year there'd
be like Skyrim on it because you know
Bethesda rolls that screen what's going
on it what is your beef with Skyrim no
so obviously disc tray mice not a tray
you start the discs in here don't this
sticker says do not move your xbox well
there's a disc inside if you in this day
and age if you are moving hardware with
spinning discs in it you deserve
everything that happens to you if your
console breaks because of that you
deserve that
no one should offer your refund that you
should you're you're guaranteed you've
avoided
alright sure hook it up yeah this work
out there we have a large TV large an
incredibly dusty and we're gonna turn on
the Xbox one X hello world it's
Microsoft's brand new powerful home
console Oh take it away
[Music]
thank you for watching this xbox1 x fun
boxing next week we'll have way more on
the console we'll be able to give you a
review and also some comparisons to the
original console and the s perhaps yeah
we'll be able to actually show you how
this bad boy stacks up against the
previous Xbox one models we can show you
all of its native 4k HDR glory that's
gonna be a lot of stuff we can do on it
yeah in the meantime you can find us on
twitter i'm pat small h I'm at Major
Nelson oh yeah I wish yes a million
followers are no I'm at Lucy James games
and four more obviously keep your eyes
peeled to gamespot.com